Think about it. Allah saying the Bible
is corrupted. They've changed it. Now if
the Bible was not
>> Where did you say that? It's
>> unbelievable.
>> That's because of his mis distortion at
279. But now notice he's going to bury
himself. If the Bible's not corrupted,
look what he says.
>> Corrupted the Quran is wrong. Right? If
the Quran is saying the Bible is
corrupted, it's been changed. If the
Bible is not corrupted, that means the
Quran is wrong. You have Christians
today. Bartman, the ex-Christian Bruce,
>> we're gonna get to Bartman in a minute.
No, the Quran says the Bible is
uncorrupt. So if the Bible is corrupt,
according to Bartman and Bruce Mezer,
she's going to misquote. Then the Quran
is a lie and it is for other reasons.
But if the Bible is not corrupt like the
Quran says, the Quran is still a lie
because it contradicts the Bible. So
he's buried either way. But now let's
talk about how he must misrepresents
Barerman and Bruce Mezer
say
>> and many of them. And when you go to the
Bible, you have footnotes. These are
added in which shows to us that the
scriptures have been changed. It's a
prophecy. But coming back to the
>> let's pop them. This again shows he's an
ignoramus.
He's stupid or he's a liar. One of the
two. What he's talking about is variant
readings in the extent manuscript
tradition
because prior to the printing press and
I'm going to now use the same criterion
to show that he just buried the Quran
with its thousands of differences
according to the extent manuscripts of
the Quran and the various and Islamic
tradition avalanche burying this guy and
his book. But let me come to the Bible
so I don't commit what's known as the
fallacy of two qui you two that's a
fallacy. Well, you too. Well, that
doesn't prove anything. It means we our
both our books are copy. Number one,
prior to the printing press, everything
is hand copy. There is no copiest that
perfectly copies. So, when you have a
copiest copying by hand under less than
desirable conditions because they didn't
have electricity, they didn't have a
printing press, they didn't have a
typewriter, they didn't have a computer,
they didn't have Microsoft, they'd have
to take a pen and ink and write.
Sometimes bad lighting. Of course,
variant readings will creep in
because it would require a miracle to
God then cause all the scribes to
produce perfect copies. But how does God
preserve the Bible? From day one when
the books of the New Testament were
written, they were copied right away and
these copies were spread all over the
then known world. This is why we have
nearly 30,000 copies of the different
books of the Bible in various languages.
nearly 30,000,
definitely over 25,000. We have about
5,300 copies in Greek of the individual
books of the New Testament. The largest
number of copies that we have of the
Bible is in Latin, nearly 10,000, most
of which have yet to be examined because
they don't have enough manpower and you
can't examine in one lifetime. So we
have nearly 30,000 at least over 25,000
that's certain of the books of the Bible
in various languages in Greek, Latin,
Aramaic, Syriak, Sahedic, Coptic,
Armenian, right? Armenian language,
Hebrew, making wholesale corruption of
the Bible humanly impossible because
it's not possible for any human being to
have gotten access of all these books
early on to then corrupt them in order
then to produce copies that that scribe
or scribes wanted to be in the Bible
from which all other copies came.
Impossible. So that's why if you have a
copy of John in the second century, the
variant readings will be different from
let's say these 20 other copies of John
from different areas in different
centuries. So we can tell then from
examining these copies the original.
This is why even Bartman himself will
tell you basically we have what they
wrote. If Bart emmon did not believe
that, he wouldn't write books on the
historical Jesus or what Paul wrote and
taught because he wouldn't know if the
copies were so corrupted that we don't
know what they originally wrote. So,
anytime Bartman tells you Paul said
this, he's assuming we have accurate
copies of what he originally wrote to
tell you what Paul said and did. So,
when Bartman writes a book like how
Jesus became God and he tells you Paul
believed this. Well, how do you know
that? All because of Philippians. But
how do you know you have Philippians
accurately preserved? See, the very fact
that Dart Man can write books telling
you what Paul believed or Peter believed
or what Jesus said means that he has
enough confidence that in the extent
manuscript copies, we can get back to
the original wording of the original
autographs.
But I'll tell you which religion did
have a committee destroy all QR copies
and standardize I'm sorry, I gave it
away. all copies and standardize the
copy that he felt should be original
Islam. It's his tradition. Bkari volume
fol 6 number 509. Sal Bkari volume 6
number 510. It's his tradition that says
that there were Qurans that were being
circulated by companions of Muhammad
that were so contradictory
that it almost led to a civil war during
the reign of man. So man ordered those
copies to be destroyed and he took a
copy made by Zed Iban Tab who became a
Muslim later on in Medina. The Zed was
what they call an Ansari meaning he only
came to Islam after Muhammad migrated to
Medina. So he wasn't there from the
beginning and he was told by Abu Bakr to
try to gather the Quran in one volume
which he did in the reign of Abu Bakr.
Abu Bakr died. That copy remained in the
possession of Umar the second Caleb. He
died and that copy went into the
possession of Umar's daughter Habsa.
Habsa bent Umar who was Muhammad's
widow. Then Uman asked her to give her
copy and as a committee of three to make
fresh copies from that copy. And then he
ordered all the other Qurans to be
collected and destroyed because they
were so different and contradictory. The
Muslims started accusing one another of
corrupting the Quran. So it is his
religion that had one man decide to
destroy all these Quranss that were
copied by companions of Muhammad who
learned the Quran directly from
Muhammad, but they couldn't even get
down what Muhammad actually told them
because they produced copies that were
so contradictory that led other Muslims
to accuse the other Muslims of
corrupting the Quran. So he had to
destroy them and sterize one copy that
he deemed to be authentic. But then it
gets worse for him. From that one Quran
arose
dozens of different Arabic versions. So
that about over 200 years later, it was
decided that seven of those different
Arabic versions called would be
standardized. And each version was
transmitted through two different means
for a total of 14 varying Quranic Arabic
versions of man's Quran and then three
others were added for a total of 17.
You now have 17 various and at times
contradictory Arabic versions of the
Omanic Quran still in circulation. The
most popular of which is the Haps
reading. And according to Muslim
sources, Haps was known as a liar who
stole books. And this is the most
popular Quranic reading based on a liar
according to Muslim tradition called the
kadab. The Bible, this is the scripture.
So we ask a very simple question. Is the
Bible the word of God? Yes. Can the word
of God be corrupted? No. Okay. If that's
the case, how do you have this many
books added in? Yeah. 86 72 73 66 this
is books books big books thrown out what
is this you're playing toys and then you
look at the verses for example
>> okay uh he's talking about the different
cannons among Christians what he what he
forgets is number one
even if we go with the different cannons
what he overlooks is at least 66 of
those books are all accepted by the
major branches of Christianity 66 of the
books do you know of any major branch of
Christianity whether Catholic or
Orthodox or Protestant rejects any of
the 27 books of the New Testament?
>> Nope. We accept all of them.
>> Now, when it comes to major branches of
Christianity like the Orthodox and the
Catholic and the Protestants, you don't
have any of them that reject the 39 Old
Testament books.
>> No.
>> So, all of us except 66. That's a given.
That's a fact. I'm talking about the
major branches of Christianity, not some
fringe group. because I can also point
to fringe Muslim groups that say the
last two verses of chapter 9 to Toba
9128129 are forgeries interpolations and
they're removed from their English
translations. There are several Qurans.
One done by Rashad Khalifa who was
murdered in the 90s for claiming to be a
messenger after Muhammad. His English
translation Rashad Khalifa in chapter 9
ends at 127. He removed rejected verses
128 129 interpolations as forgeries that
should not be there. and his followers
after him under the headship of Edyp
Yuko produced a translation of the Quran
called Quran a reformist translation
which you can download as a PDF col PDF
file online. They too end their chapter
at verse 127. So if you read chapter 9
they end it at 127 and they have a note
saying why 128 129 are not revealed.
They're not part of the crown. They're
forgeries. So if he wants to play that
game, we can appeal to these fringe
groups that'll say, "Well, they're
fringe groups. They're heretics. They're
QR only." Okay, let's go with the major
branches of Christianity versus Islam.
According to the major branches
Christianity, there is no debate. 66
books, authoritative, inspired,
preserved. We all agree on that. Now
when it comes to Protestantism, it's the
Protestants that later on expuned what
we call the dudero chronicles which are
the seven books that the Orthodox and
the Catholic accept. They accept those
seven books. The Orthodox have a few
more books, but the duter can chronicles
that are found in Catholic Bibles. Even
Orthodox Bibles, the Protestants removed
even though up until 1820s, this is a
fact. And you guys, if you want to find
more information, go to Gary Machuda's
YouTube channel, Apocalypse. Apocrypha
Apocalypse. Apocrypha Apocalypse. It's a
YouTube channel devoted entirely on the
historical evidence for the canonicity
of the dutonicals, which Orthodox and
Catholic accept in common. He did a
series when the duo canonical removed.
And by Deuteronomicals I'm talking about
those old testament books like first and
second Mcabes like Tobit Judith wisdom
of Solomon wisdom of Ben Sak those are
the books that the orthodox Catholic
call dudero canonicals which the
protestants call apocrypha. He has
documented from actual historical
sources that all Protestant Bibles, even
the English translations, because when I
say Protestant Bibles, I'm talking about
Martin Luther's German Bible and even
Protestant Bibles in English up until
1820s, all of them included the Duro
Canonicals, though they re relegated
them to secondary status. They said,
"These books are helpful historical to
be read, but they're not part of the
canon, so we can't use them to determine
doctrine." Even Martin Luther's German
Bible included them. It was part of his
Bible and all Protestant Bibles until
the 1820s where a reformed Protestant
denomination decided, "Let's remove them
because we don't believe they're
canonical in order to make Bibles
cheaper to produce." And it was part of
the King James Bible.
>> This is a fact. The original 1611
included the Deuteronomicals. They were
translated by the 54 scholars
commissioned by the King of England to
produce the King James Bible. And it was
part of all printings of the King James
Bible until the 1880s. So, it's the
Protestants that removed them.
>> Yep. Right. And by the way, don't forget
the point. If we go to his his history,
the companions of Muhammad could not
agree how many chapters
make up the Quran. Abd Abdullahbin
Massud who whom Muhammad mentioned first
of the four to learn the Quran from only
had 111. He said surah faty chapter one
and chapters 113 114 are not part of the
Quran. their prayers. Ubi bin Kab which
is one of the other four men that
Muhammad mentioned and whom Bkari says
was labeled the master of the Quranic
reciters had 116 chapters but Otman went
with 114. People living in glass houses
should shut their mouth.
>> Yep. All right.
>> John 7:53 to Mike Mark 81. There's
passages taken out. They realize it's
not in the original manuscripts. Yeah.
So, how can I trust? I
>> This is lie. He's talking about John
7:5311 and Mark 69-20.
Number one, they're not taken out.
They're there. There are modern scholars
who would say they're not what John and
Mark originally wrote, but the evidence
is overwhelming. Massive historical
archeological evidence showing they are
original. John did write John 7:5311 and
Mark did write Mark 16:9 to to 20. In
fact,
of all the extent copies of Mark that
have Mark 16,
about 99% of them have the longer
ending. And James uh Snap does a good uh
>> excellent. In fact, invite him on your
channel to give you the historical
archaeological case because I've had him
on. He's got two free ebooks on the
evidence and he's got his own YouTube
channel and his blog, but he does
interviews. He's done some for me, but
invite him on your channel because part
of the Orthodox church, you go with the
Byzantine text, the majority text. And
in your church, which is the true
historic church established by the
apostles, preserved by the spirit, you
go with the canonicity of John 7:53,
811, and Mark 16:9-20. So, you owe it to
your audience to have him on because
he's not orthodox. He's just being
honest with the facts. Well, so yes, the
evidence is overwhelming. I don't know
what this guy's talking about because
he's a parrot who can't even parrot the
arguments correctly because he's stupid.
>> And just quickly, just before he was
saying this, Ali Daw was saying this
stuff, he was also saying who do we pray
to? The father, the son, and the holy
spirit. Just quickly just uh address
that. Yeah.
>> All three. The Bible says if the father
is truly God and the son is truly God,
the holy spirit is truly God. They are,
then they're worthy of worship. So
that's why you find in the Bible prayer
is directed to all three. Now just I'll
give you the verses. Everyone knows that
we pray to the father. So I don't think
we need to prove that point. There is no
doubt we pray to the father. John
15:16-23
our lord says that if you ask the father
in his name the father will do it. But
where do we find prayers to the son?
Okay. Well John 143 and 14. Guys you got
to write down those who are coming later
because it's pre-recorded because we
don't have time to go through all of it.
So where do we find prayers to the son?
John 14:13-14.
Okay. Acts 1, you got to read Acts 1
24-2. But in the context, you're going
to know they're praying to Jesus. In
Acts 1 24:25, they're praying to Jesus.
How do we know? Because you read Acts
1:2, Acts 1 6 and 7, Acts 1:21, and then
24:25. And there you're going to see the
Lord who knows the hearts of all men
that they pray to is Jesus Christ. So
Acts 1 24:25, Acts 759-60.
Stephen, when he's about to die, Lord
Jesus, receive my spirit. Lord, do not
hold this against them. Acts 9 verse14
and 21 there the Lord appears to Ananas.
So here the Lord appears in visions and
Ananas is praying directly to him. But
there Ananas mentions that Paul is
persecuting all those everywhere
starting in Jerusalem who call on the
name of the Lord Jesus Christ. Calling
on the name of the Lord Jesus is an Old
Testament practice that in involves
invoking God, praying to God, asking
God, praising God, worshiping God. And
yet the Jews in Jerusalem and Christians
all over were calling on the name of the
Lord Jesus. Something that can only be
ascribed to God. And that's in 1
Corinthians 1:2. All those everywhere
who are calling on the name of the Lord
Jesus Christ. 1 Corinthians 1:2. 1
Corinthians 16:22 a prayer to the Lord
come. Our Lord come. Right? 2
Corinthians 12 7-10.
1 Timothy 1 12 all the way to 17. And on
and on it goes when it comes to the
Lord. And another thing you'll find,
you'll find that in the beginning of the
epistles and typically at the end, an
invocation for blessings on the
recipients of the letters. So when Paul
writes to Corinth, he says, "Grace to
you and peace from God the Father and
the Lord Jesus Christ." That's a prayer.
But he's praying to the father and the
son to bestow spiritual blessings
equally jointly upon the Christians who
are reading this letter. And this is
what Paul does. This is what John does.
Like in 2 John 1:3, he invokes God the
father and from Jesus Christ the father
son to bestow peace and blessing on the
recipients of the letter. So there you
find this repeated pattern of invoking
the father son together. What about the
spirit? 2 Corinthians 13:14.
It's a benediction again, an invocation
to God to bless the recipients and
readers of this epistle. So how does
Paul end it? By praying to father, son,
holy spirit. Because he says 2
Corinthians 13:14,
the grace of Jesus Christ. The love of
God and the fellowship of the Holy
Spirit be with you all. That's a prayer
to the father, son, and holy spirit. And
notice they don't even care who they
begin with. Here he starts with the son
and ends with the spirit. Now if the son
was inferior in a creature, it is
blasphemy to pray to a creature to
bestow any blessing because only God
bestows. Even in communion saints, we
ask the saints to pray to God to bestow.
We don't ask them to do it. We ask them
to pray to God to do it. So to ask
Jesus, if he's a creature, to bestow
blessings, blasphemy. And to start with
Jesus, if he's not equal to God, a
blasphemy, right? And then Philippians
3:3, it says, "The true circumcision,
those who are truly circumcised in the
sight of God are those who are
spiritually circumcised, born of the
spirit, and they are the ones who
worship the spirit of God." Literally,
the Greek says it is we who are the true
circumcision, who the spirit of God
worship. And there Paul uses latuo. Lu
is the worship given to God alone
according to Jesus in Matthew 4:10.
There you go.
>> Amen. Perfect, brother.